our last application
of constrained least squares is linear
quadratic state estimation
like the other two applications you can
take an entire course on nothing but
this
and it's also like the other two very
widely used in a lot of application
areas
it's got other names like kalman filter
or something like that
but it's still used everywhere all right
let me give you the setting actually the
setting is very similar to the control
problem uh but uh actually the problem
is quite different although they are
they are also closely related i'll
explain that so we start with a linear
dynamic system model
that's exactly what we did before oh
there's a bit of a difference here
in fact a bunch is different so i'm
going to emphasize it compared to
control
so here um i have an input
but i'm using the traditional term wt
so wt is actually not an input that we
have control over
wt is actually supposed to be like a
weird disturbance
or or measure it's something like um
it's process noise or input
disturbance right that that's that's the
idea and here
yt is not just ctxt it's also got this
vt term
and vt is the measurement noise or
measurement residual and that's a p
vector so that's a
so you have these measurements um that's
the idea
now in the state estimation problem uh
here here's the here's a statement of
the problem
i'll tell you what a t b t c t are and
i'm going to tell you what the
measurements are y1 through yt so that
that you know and your job is this
estimate or guess the state sequence
that's that's the goal okay um
oh i should say that these two noises
the process noise
and the measurement noise wt and vt
they're they're not known uh but they're
assumed to be small
and that's going to be how we're going
to formulate a constrained least squares
problem out of this to
to solve state estimation problem
okay so here here's how we're going to
formulate it
we're going to say we're going to
minimize again there are two objectives
so and basically what he's come down to
is
uh very simple um this is nothing that's
v
one uh this is v capital t
and so basically that the two terms are
here we can either come up with a state
sequence where we make
the w's small or we can make the the v
small and that's actually these are the
two objectives and of course we're going
to scalarize it
and with a with a positive parameter uh
in between them
to trade off and so this is the
measurement error
plus the uh process error and then we'd
say subject to the dynamics right so
so what we're really going to do is the
is where
the states are the very the state the
variables in our optimization
are going to be the state sequence also
the input noise sequence right
no we don't care about the input noise
sequence but the idea is we need it so
that we can express the idea that it's
small
okay um so here they are the measurement
noise is simply the sum of the squares
of the vts
um the secondary objective is going to
be the sum of squares of the process
noise
um and lambda as i said uh is a
parameter that we can trade off
now i should say here in the state
estimation problem
unlike the control problem we're
actually going to have
a non-ad hoc a a principal
method by which to choose lambda we'll
see that we're going to be able to do
that by cross validation
so that's coming later all right
so we are going to take this problem and
we are going to do the same thing we did
in the control and we're simply going to
make it a giant constrained least
squares problem
i i say giant because you know it could
have
thousands of variables but again it is
just simply
not a non-problem so okay
so um all right here it is so this is
our
objective uh here's our objective it's
we have to minimize the
the the sum of the squares of the
process noise plus lambda times the sum
of the squares
sorry sum of the squares of the
measurement errors
noise plus this lambda times the sum of
the squares of the processed noise
that's the w's
um and so again we're going to write it
as a
giant constrained least squares problem
the we're going to
concatenate all the all the vectors
together into one vector
all of our variables so x1 up to xt w1
up to wt minus one which is going to
concatenate them into one vector
and now we have to say what is a tilde c
tilde and d tilde
um well here they are um actually they
look
shockingly close to the same to the
matrices you saw in the control case
um they are very very very close um and
that
hasn't escaped people uh the fact that
there's this
very close mathematical connection
between the control problem
and the estimation problem in fact i
guess people refer to these as dual
problems which i'm not going to go into
but it means that they're
intimately related note that they're
actually very different though
right in in the control problem there's
an input that we imagine that we have
control over
and we're saying what should it be like
how should i operate my airplane you
know or something like that right
um here however uh
if we we observe some measurements um
and uh and the goal is to estimate the
state so it's really uh it's a bit
different
okay so i won't go into auditing this or
maybe we can take a look at one one
you know these i think by now you should
be able to read this that c
tilde times z equals d tilde this first
row
is basically a state update it says a1
times x1
minus x2 that's this term that's a1
times x1 minus x2
plus b1 u1 equals zero but that's
that's the that's the state that says x2
is a
is a1 x1 plus uh b1
u1 that's so this is dynamics equations
okay
so we solve this problem um and and uh
and it's just a big constraintly squares
problem it's once again very sparse so
we can solve it
extremely efficiently actually even more
efficiently than that because it's more
than
it's actually not just sparse but it
actually has a structure called banded
it doesn't matter it's just we can solve
it super efficiently okay
um now we're going to talk about
something else which is
missing measurements and this is going
to be
our pathway to a rational method
uh a non-ad hoc method for choosing the
the parameter uh in in here the the
uh the lambda okay so
missing measurements goes like this um
let's suppose they have a bunch of
measurements
uh yt uh but only for t
uh in in in for certain times so for
example
at certain times you just don't get any
measurements oh by the way i should say
we can make this even more complicated
and say that certain
individual components of y usually are
associated with different sensors
and so like we could say that oh in any
time period
one or more cent sensors might fail and
then
so we can make this more complicated if
we like but this is good enough
um so we do is we just say at certain
times we just we have no measurements
just there just aren't any sorry i'd
like we don't have any measurement
uh okay and so script t is going to be
the
subset of one to t for which we have
measurements
right so and if if you want to think of
measurements uh there'd be a typical
application of this in navigation
um we could be trying to figure out you
know
where where we are
or where a target is and the different
measurements could be things like
multiple radars uh illuminating it and
making an estimate of position or
something like that
or if it's on a single it's a single
airplane
you could be attempting your estimates
could be things like
um it could be accelerometers
uh some kind of a radar altimeter uh
it could be all sorts of things like
that okay
um okay uh
all right um oh measurements for t i
should say there we go
not in t are missing there we go small
typo that's fine
um so to estimate the states you use the
same formulation
but what we do is we only of course
uh take the um we
what we do is only for the for only only
for when we have the measurements
uh do we do we contribute to this j
mesh thing okay um
now if i when i perform the state
estimation problem i'm going to get
x sub t for t not in script t
and then that's going to be my estimate
of y hat
yeah and you can see that we're getting
i mean you should be
it's kind of cool because you'd say well
i didn't make that measurement in that i
didn't get a measurement that period
and and then we can say oh yeah well we
think
the measurement would have been had you
had a measurement it would have been
y t hat which is c x t hat okay
um now by the way that's the key to
being able to cross validate obviously
because
i just i pretend that a measurement
didn't come in
and i don't have it but the truth is i
have it in other words i keep it i
i keep it in reserve exactly as in data
fitting it becomes a
test measurement okay so i don't give it
to the state estimator
and the state estimator still pretends
it's missing and says oh sorry i don't
have that
it estimates it and then the state
estimator is going to make a prediction
of that
but i've secretly held back the actual
measurement yt
and now i can compare yt and yt hat and
if they're close my state estimator is
doing really well and that's exactly the
same as like an out of
you know out of sample test or some kind
of validation test in data fitting
that it's precisely that
all right so we're going to look at an
example um and
it's got uh that's the the dynamics
matrix a they're constant that's b
that's c and this is essentially uh
a it's a very simple model of a mass
moving in a two-dimensional plane
where x-t is its position and its
velocity right each of which is a two
vector so it's a four-vector
um and then what we're going to get is
we're going to get the true position
that's ct xd plus wt and that's going to
be a noisy measurement of position
so what c says is we're going to get a
position we're going to get a position s
at the x and y position estimates and
there'll be noise on it so it's actually
quite simple we have 100 we'll do a
horizon of 100 time steps okay
so let's take a look at it so here's
here's uh here's what you would know the
input to the
state estimation problem the green
circles
show us the actual measurements made
right
the black line shows you the actual
trajectory
of the state okay now of course in the
state estimation problem
we don't know the dark line right that's
in fact the whole goal is to guess the
dark line
now you know you can look at this and
your eyeball can see that
you know these are the estimates of the
state um
your eyeball can see that you know it
looks something like the black line
because they kind of follow each other
okay so hopefully that will emerge from
from this state estimation method
okay so we have 100 noisy measurements
all right let's do state estimation
now um with different values of lambda
um so here's lambda equals one and and
the blue line
shows you our state estimate and um
okay look your eyeball tells you right
up right away well
look that's not good because it's it's
actually what people would say it's
following the noise
that's what it is that this one is
um when lambda is a thousand that's
doing very nicely thank you that's that
is that is actually a very nice estimate
right there
of the state um and was 10 to the 5
um it's not a good estimate now and um
and i i you know we can we can easily uh
explain this um roughly speaking when
lambda is one it means you trust the
sensor these
are these noisy sensor measurements
that's these green circles
you trust them too much and as a result
your estimate of where are you
is wiggling around too much i'm
anthropomorphizing this but you get the
idea
um when lambda is 10 to the 5 basically
you're saying you
barely trust you don't trust the sensors
like at all
and so you want you want to what you're
going to do is have large sensor errors
to explain what it is and so you end up
with something that looks like that
right so that's the idea okay now
in this case well okay we know what the
exact solution is
it's kind of clear that lambda equals 10
to the 3 is about right
but let's see how we would do this with
cross validation or validation i should
say
so here's what we do we just randomly
remove 27 of the measurements
and and use that as a test set then
what we do is for you know uh some you
know 10
20 30 values of lambda we do the
complete estimation problem
um and we use the other measurements and
when they say what happened to the 20
percent of measurements
aren't there we just say missing just
missing
okay it's a lie we actually have those
measurements we're just holding them in
escrow so that we can actually see how
well our system works
our state estimation works and then what
we do is we evaluate the rms measurement
error
on the test set that's fair because
we're actually
you know we've held back those things
and we're actually checking like how
how big is the rms then what you do is
you choose lambda to approximately
minimize the rms test residuals
sound familiar it should because this is
exactly data fitting with
regularization okay so for that example
this is what it looks like
as i increase lambda
on the training set i just get worse and
worse right um
but on the test set it's actually super
interesting that
as i increase lambda i start i actually
start doing better
i go from you know above 40 down to
i don't even know what that is high
twenties right and it also kind of
suggests you should pick lambda right in
there which is you know coincidentally
what we did
um now above that is is you get very bad
uh examples and sure enough lambda
equals 10 to the three
here is quite reasonable and now
look the reason you want a method like
that
is is this is that obviously in real
applications
we don't know the state the actual true
state trajectory we don't know it
because
that's the whole point of the problem is
to estimate the state trajectory so you
don't have this
uh this black line here to guide you not
to mention
this doesn't happen usually in two
dimensions or whatever because there are
four dimensions because
that's just way too small a problem
right so this is
uh and then you like you're on your own
trying to figure it out and that's
exactly where
um this kind of cross validation method
uh
will actually allow you to do this